[Music]
the global disparity in vaccinations has
left billions of people in poorer
countries vulnerable to covert 19.
inoculating only half the world also
increases the risk of a new variant
arising that could resist the vaccines
[Music]
that would endanger people in developed
countries too
no matter how many times they'd been
vaccinated
the world health organization is
sounding the alarm
not to have equitable distribution of
vaccines
is not only a question
of being immoral it is also a question
of being stupid
the who's kovacs initiative has seen
more than 300 million doses shipped to
more than 140 countries
far less than what's needed
[Music]
i'm ben fazoulen as the global death
toll from covert climbs health experts
are urging more people to get the jab
not just for your own good but for those
more vulnerable or who don't yet have
access
the longer this takes the more people
will die
[Music]
the size and scale of the covid19
pandemic makes it a one in a hundred
year event
not since the spanish flu killed more
than 50 million people after the first
world war has the world seen anything
like it
today nearly five million people have
died from the coronavirus
almost 50 percent of the world's
population has received at least one
dose of a vaccine but for low-income
countries that figure drops to around
three percent i'm afraid that the world
is in danger of moving on too quickly
not learning the lessons and
not making the reforms that are
necessary in order to be better prepared
for the next pandemic or other
challenges the world will face and
i hope i'm wrong in that
but i do see signs of um of uh countries
moving on already and going back to
business as usual and the more
nationalistic agenda and i
i
i would sincerely regret that it would
be uh an amazingly stupid thing to do
the world health organization is warning
that vaccine nationalism will prolong
the pandemic and leave the world's
poorest and most vulnerable people at
risk
britain for example has now vaccinated
more than 70 percent of its population
it ended its covid19 restrictions in
july
in contrast to that ethiopia has jabbed
less than three percent of its
population
but vaccines are just one part of the
picture
scientists say we are entering an age of
pandemics
so many will be hoping the lessons from
kovid19 are taken on board sooner rather
than later
emily cameron blake is part of the covet
19 government response tracker at oxford
university she joins us from edinburgh
firstly what about this call today from
some g20 leaders to redistribute surplus
vaccines to low-income countries
hi ben thanks for having me
um
yeah this is an interesting call and
quite frankly i think quite warranted um
these g20 countries have amassed
huge surpluses of vaccines and quite
frankly they don't necessarily need them
at this point in time so calling on them
to redistribute them to low-income
countries who are in desperate need is a
much asked for call
however the problem with it is that it
places the onus on kovacs if they're
simply donated to kovacs kovacs has the
responsibility of distributing them so i
think the even bigger ask is asking them
to deploy those vaccines as well
earlier on in the crisis it was just
canada that was amassing so many
vaccines but that seems to have been
replicated time and again and there's
data out showing how much more prolific
the booster shots are in wealthier
countries
yeah no exactly and you know i think
numbers that have come out just in the
past 24 hours show us that there are
actually three times as many doses being
distributed in boosters to high-income
countries as there are to actual doses
of initial vaccine in these low-income
countries so about 1 million doses a day
of booster shots versus about 330 000
doses a day of first doses of vaccines
in these low-income countries
now the german health minister just got
the got his booster saying there's
enough for everyone here to get their
third
shot so
should i feel bad about getting the
booster or am i actually helping stop
covert from spreading because
that is one of the fears of course is
that it continues to be spread and
spread around the world
yeah it's a good question and
i think this is a bit of a moral
question isn't it it's um obviously if
there's enough boosters in your country
for you to have your third dose or your
booster um you know should you feel bad
about that and i think that that
actually just goes back to this question
of
do we need them and i'm not
epidemiologist i can't answer that um
but you know other others who actually
need them more and that's where the
question of vaccine equality versus
vaccine equity really comes into play
isn't it a case that these countries
will have to spend a lot more money to
get their health systems up to scratch
because traditionally they haven't spent
that much on health care and the
pandemic has highlighted that
yeah precisely and so what's happening
is that not only are they low-income
countries but they also tend to be
low-capacity countries so they're
already dealing with lower budgets than
high-income countries and they've had to
focus on different health care costs and
now the the ravage that kovid has put on
them is really placing them in a
position where those health care costs
are soaring to at least twice if not
more than what they normally are whereas
the extra cost on some of these
high-income countries is
almost negligible
so
how should the wealthier nations be
helping out is it not just in
redistributing but also in
uh i don't know uh supporting the the
the building up of these healthcare
systems in other countries i mean we're
talking about tanzania one percent as
far as uh vaccination goes nigeria two
percent as we heard just before ethiopia
uh just below three percent whereas half
the world has already received at least
one dose
yeah i think you know going back to what
i said about the g20 leaders you know
donating this surplus of vaccines is a
start but also you know they've got the
ability and the capacity to help with
the distribution of it so you know not
just donating to kovacs and letting
kovacs get on with it but actually
donating them to kovacs and then helping
with that infrastructure they have to be
delivered to rural parts of countries in
sub-saharan africa um you know that's
that's not an easy task and that takes a
lot of manpower and a lot of human
resource and financial resource that
those countries can't afford at this
point at this point in time
one more thing again it all comes back
to the fact that none of us will be
properly protected until the whole world
is inoculated
yep very true
so as as long as there are huge
parts of the world and population that
are unvaccinated you know it's been
alluded to these new variants um that's
that's the breeding ground for new
variants is an unvaccinated population
and
until we've closed that gap and made
sure that everyone has some form of
adequate protection from
there really is
no end in sight
emily cameron blake thank you very much
for being on the show today
thank you thanks for having me
here's a good question now for anyone
who desperately holds their breath while
walking through a cloud of someone
else's youth smoke
is there any evidence covet 19 can be
spread more by smokers
think back for a minute to the early
days of the pandemic and and you might
faintly remember something called
the nicotine hypothesis which was
based on a couple of studies indicating
that smokers maybe didn't get coveted 19
as often as non-smokers do now
there's still really no clear evidence
for that claim but but scientific
battles are still being fought over it
which just goes to show you how loaded
the topic of smoking during a pandemic
with a respiratory disease how loaded
that can be
the question of whether smokers spread
covet more than non-smokers
is another one
that's almost impossible to answer with
a study i mean
how would you design it
but there are several
indisputable aspects of the debate
that they're mentioning that might help
you reach your own conclusions
first is that we know
masking helps cut covet transmission and
it's impossible to smoke with a mask on
um
second
is that smokers
tend to exhale their smoke extensively
and and forcefully in a way that that
researchers say is actually closer
to to shouting or singing than it is to
normal breathing
and we know that when infected people
shout or sing
that can dramatically increase the
chance that they'll infect others
third is that smoking involves
repeatedly putting your hands up close
to and and on your mouth okay we've
learned
that surface transmission mostly isn't a
big danger but but still
i think that most experts would say
regularly touching your lips during a
pandemic
is probably a bad idea um a few other
things are even more clear like
when smokers do get coveted 19 it's more
likely to take a deadly turn and also
we know that pandemic or no pandemic
smoking is just terrible for your health
and and it's also
bad for the people around you
whether you spread the virus more or not
[Music]